ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHANGE [inaudible]
DOT.
THE ROUTE SO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
HUESO -- TADA [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA.
MCGUIRE.
MITCHELL MONNING.
MORE LOCK.
MERRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO ROTH.
RUBIO SKINNER STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
NUMBER WHY CASSIE WIENER WELL.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WITH A MEMBERS IN OUR GUESTS BE
ON THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE.
WILL BE LED PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY OUR CHAPLAIN SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING A WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
BY SENATOR BRIAN JONES.
LET US BE STILL IN GOD'S
PRESENCE.
ST AUGUSTINE SAID.
HOPE HAS TWO BEAUTIFUL DAUGHTERS.
THEIR NAMES ARE ANGER AND
COURAGE.
ANGER AT THE WAY THINGS ARE.
AND COURAGE TO SEE BUT THEY DO
NOT TO REMAIN THE WAY THEY ARE
[inaudible]
GRACIOUS GOD.
EACH DAY OUR HOPE IN THE
GOODNESS OF HUMAN KIND IS
CHALLENGED.
AS WE SEEM NOT TO LEARN FROM THE
MISTAKES OF OUR PAST.
FORGIVE THOSE WHO WERE COMPLICIT
IN THE ATROCITIES OF THE
HOLOCAUST.
BY LACKING THE COURAGE TO
CHALLENGE THE INJUSTICES OF
ACTING.
FORGIVE US FOR OUR COMPLICITY IN
THE ATROCITIES OF THESE DAYS.
WHEN WE ALLOW THINGS TO REMAIN
AS THEY ARE?
HOPING FOR DIFFERENT RESULTS.
TODAY WE PRAY IN THANKSGIVING.
FOR ALL THOSE WHO ACT WITH
COURAGE. TO PUT THE NEEDS OF
ANOTHER BEFORE THEIR OWN SAFETY.
WE PRAY FOR THOSE WHOSE
RIGHTEOUS ANGER FIRES THEM UP.
TO PUSH FOR IMPROVEMENTS IN THE
LIVES OF THOSE WHO SUFFER.
WE PRAY FOR A SPIRIT OF NON
VIOLENCE FOR ALL OF US.
AS WE ENCOUNTER THE CHALLENGES
OF EACH DAY.
MAY THOSE WHO LIVE LIVES OF FEAR
AND PREJUDICE BE TRANSFORMS.
BY THE MYSTERY OF YOUR GRACE.
AND BY OUR CONTINUED EFFORTS TO
CREATE A WORLD OF PEACE HARMONY
AND UNITY FOR ALL A MAN.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO OUR GREAT COUNTRY.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE ONE NATION UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE WITH.
ITSELF.
IF MEMBERS EGHT MEMBERS COULD I
TAKE THEIR SEATS AT THIS TIME.
AS WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A MOMENT
OF SILENCE. FOR THE TRAGIC
EVENTS THAT OCCURRED IN IN SAN
DIEGO THIS WEEKEND AT THAT POWER
AWAY SYNAGOGUE.
RAY AT A MOMENT'S SILENCE FOR
THOSE THAT LOST THEIR LIVES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION IS
WILL MOVE TO SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY ONE ITEM.
EIGHTY SIX SENATOR ALLEN ARE YOU
PREPARED I AM THIS PRESS
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FORTY ONE
BY SENATOR ALAN REAL TO TO
CALIFORNIA HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL
DAY.
MISS PRESENT MEMBERS I RISE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LESS OF
JEWISH CAUCUS. TWO PRESENTS
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
FORTY ONE THIS ESOLUTION
COMMEMORATES HOLOCAUST MEMBERS
MURMURED STAY OR YOUNG HIGH SO I
AS YOU MUST SHOW AS WE SEE IN
HEBREW WHICH JEWS AROUND THE
WORLD WILL COMMEMORATE.
ON WEDNESDAY AND THURSDAY.
HI YOU KNOW I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY WHEN I WAS A COLLEGE
STUDENT. TWENTY YEARS AGO.
TO WALKED THE HALLOWED AND GO
STILL GROUNDS ABOUT SHADES.
AND IT WAS ONE MOST POWERFUL
DAYS OF MY LIFE AND I WAS TWENTY
YEARS AGO.
THIS YEAR [inaudible]
AND IT'S HARD FOR ME TO IMAGINE
THAT THE SAME DARK FIRE THAT LED.
THE JEWISH PEOPLE AND AND MANY
OTHER.
MINORITY FOLKS TO THE GAS
CHAMBERS AT THE END OF THOSE
TRAIN TRACKS WOULD CONTINUE TO
FLICKER.
HERE IN OUR OWN COUNTRY
[inaudible]
TODAY.
IN OUR BEAUTIFUL CITIES LIKE
CHARLOTTESVILLE [inaudible]
PITTSBURGH.
AND NOW POWER WAY.
IN OUR OWN STATE.
IT'S THE SECOND SYNAGOGUE
SHOOTING IN SIX MONTHS.
REMINDS US THAT WE HAVE NOT YET
FULLY LEARN THE LESSONS OF THE
HOLOCAUST.
JUST YESTERDAY MEMBERS OF OUR
CAUCUS AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE WERE ABLE TO MEET
WITH SURVIVORS AT THE LOS
ANGELES MUSEUM OF THE HOLOCAUST
IN A ELECTION.
WHERE WE TALKED ABOUT?
THEIR EXPERIENCES WE HEARD
HORRIFIC STORIES. ONE THAT IS
STRUCK ME.
SO MUCH MORE NOW THAT I HAVE A
CHILD THAT.
WHEN THE STORY THAT WAS REPEATED
TO US WAS OF A MOTHER?
WHO WAS LITERALLY BALANCE TO HER
TWO DAUGHTERS?
BY THE RIVER BANK.
AND SHOT BECAUSE THE ****
SOLDIERS IN ONE AND WASTE. THREE
BULLETS.
THIS PARTICULAR SURVIVOR WAS ONE
OF THE LITTLE GIRLS WHO HAPPEN
TO MIRACULOUSLY SURVIVED.
AND WE WERE TOLD BY THE
SURVIVORS WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
HOLOCAUST WE'RE NOT TALK ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED YEARS AGO WE'RE
TALK ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
YESTERDAY.
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT THE SAME.
SPARK OF ANTI SEMITISM.
THAT LED TO THEIR DEATHS THAT
CONTINUES TODAY [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THE THE THE SAD THING IS THAT
WE'VE BEEN FAILING THESE
INCREDIBLE HEROES THESE THESE
SURVIVORS ACCIDENT OR SEMITISM
IN AMERICA HAVE INCREASED BY
OVER 60% SINCE.
TWENTY SIXTEEN ALONGSIDE A RISE
IN ACTS OF HOMOPHOBIA
TRANSPHOBIA SEXISM RACISM.
XENA PHOBIA AND ISLAMOPHOBIA.
THESE BIASES ARE SYSTEMIC.
I WAS NOT LOST ON ME THAT THE
GREAT INSPIRATION OF THIS.
TROUBLED YOUNG MAN WHO SHOT UP
THE SYNAGOGUE IN POWAY.
WAS THE SHOOTER IN CHRISTCHURCH
[inaudible]
WHO SHOT?
AT IT IS IN MUSLIMS.
IN THEIR MáS IN THEIR HOUSES OF
WORSHIP.
THE SATURDAYS THEY WERE FEELING
OUR NEXT GENERATION A STUDY
CONDUCTED JUST LAST YEAR
REVEALED THAT TWO THIRDS OF
MILLENNIALS.
DON'T KNOW WHAT OUTFITS WAS.
ALMOST A QUARTER HAVEN'T EVEN
HEARD OF THE WHOLE COST.
THAT'S WHY COMMEMORATIONS LIKE
THIS.
AND LIKE THAT WHICH IS GOING ON
OVER IN THE ASSEMBLY SIDE RIGHT
NOW ARE ABSOLUTELY CRUCIAL.
AFTER THE IMAGES CIRCULATED OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS MARKING **** SALUTES
AND CELEBRATING AROUND CUTS
ARRANGES SWASTIKA.
THE LOS ANGELES MUSEUM OF THE
HOLOCAUST INVITED THOSE SEEM
STUDENTS TO THEIR MUSEUM.
AND FOLLOWING THEIR VISIT THE
STUDENTS WROTE HEARTFELT LETTERS.
EXPRESSING THEIR REMORSE IN
THEIR NEW FOUND UNDERSTANDING OF
THE DANGERS.
OF THEIR ACTIONS.
SO THERE ARE SOME REASONS FOR
OPTIMISM AND HOPE BEFORE ABLE TO
PUT.
THE TIME IN THE ENERGY IN THE
RESOURCES INTO THESE KINDS OF
THIS KIND OF WORK.
THE JEWISH CAUCUS REMAINS
COMMITTED TO LIFTING UP STORIES
THE HOLOCAUST YEAR AFTER YEAR TO
EDUCATE TO HONOR AND TO REMEMBER.
WE HONOR THOSE WHO LOST
EVERYTHING YET PERSISTED IN
REBUILDING.
WE HONOR THE RIGHTEOUS YOUR
WRIST EVERYTHING TO PROTECT
OTHERS.
WE HONOR THE LIBERATORS WHO LEFT
THEIR HOMES.
AND RISK THEIR LIVES TO ENTER A
WAR IN PURSUIT.
OF UNIVERSAL FREEDOM.
I WE REMEMBER WE REMEMBER THE
CONSEQUENCES OF SENSELESS HATRED.
THE JEWS AND OTHER MINORITY
COMMUNITIES.
ARE OFTEN TARGETS THE COMPASSION
CAN CHANGE THE WORLD.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING I.
C. R. FORTY ONE TO HONOR AND
REMEMBER THE VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS OF THE HOLOCAUST.
OF PITTSBURGH IN A POWER WAY.
AND OF ALL HATE MOTIVATED
VIOLENCE IN TO USE THESE LESSONS
IN OUR FIGHT.
AGAINST INJUSTICE EVERYWHERE.
I ASK YOUR RIVAL [inaudible]
CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENTE
SENATOR SAW ON BEHALF OF THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS YEAR --
FORTY ONE AND TO ESTABLISH
CALIFORNIA HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL
DAY AND WHY THANK MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM SANTA MONICA FOR HIS
ELOQUENT WORDS IT'S HARD TO
FOLLOW THEM -- YOU KNOW THE
DARKEST MOMENT OF THE PAST
CENTURY TWENTIETH CENTURY ADOLPH
HITLER LETTER GENOCIDE THAT
RESULT IN THE SENSE OF DEATH.
OF ONE MILLION PEOPLE.
IN THIS RESOLUTION ENSURES OUR
FUTURE GENERATIONS WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN ABOUT THIS
UNFORTUNATE.
WELL THAT'S AN UNDERSTATEMENT --
TRAGEDY IN OUR WORLD HISTORY.
AND WE NEED TO LEARN THIS
HISTORY SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE
THAT GENOCIDE LIKE THE HOLOCAUST
NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN.
WHAT WE SAY NEVER FORGET WE MUST
REMEMBER TO SURVIVORS OF THIS
HORRIFIC TRAGEDY ARE PASSING
AWAY?
AND SO WE NEED TO BE SURE THAT
OUR GENERATION AND THE
GENERATIONS THAT FOLLOW MUST
KEEP THE MEMORY ALIVE.
IS UNFORTUNATE THERE ARE SOME
WHO ARE OUT THERE WHO WOULD
DIMINISH THE SUFFERING OF THE
JEWISH PEOPLE.
WHO WOULD DENY OR EVEN MOCK THE
HOLOCAUST AND FORTUNATE SEEN
THIS HAPPEN?
BUT THIS DAY IS ABOUT
RECOGNIZING THE STRENGTH AND
COURAGE NEEDED TO FIGHT
INJUSTICE.
JEWISH AMERICAN ORGANIZATIONS
PLAYED A CYNIC SIGNIFICANT ROLES
COALITION PARTNERS WITH JAPANESE
AMERICAN WORKSTATIONS AND
ADVOCATING REDRESS FOR JAPANESE
AMERICAN INTERNMENT.
THIS WEEK'S VIOLENCE SHOOTING AT
A SYNAGOGUE ON PO A IS A TRAGIC
AN URGENT REMINDER THAT WE MUST
NOT KEEP SILENT.
IN THE FACE OF BIGOTRY AND
HATRED.
WE MUST STAND UNITED ACROSS ALL
FAITHS AND BACKGROUNDS AND WORK
TOGETHER.
BY SPEAKING OUT FOR PEACE AND
FOR JUSTICE.
SO I TO URGE -- THAT WOULD COME
TOGETHER AND VOTE HI ON THIS
RESOLUTION SO WE CAN REFLECT
BOTH ON THE LIVES IN THE
MEMORIES.
OF PEOPLE LOST IN THE HOLOCAUST
AND AGAIN DEDICATE OURSELVES TO
SAY NEVER AGAIN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SAID PAN SENATOR
JACKSON'S.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE.
AT THIS MOMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS THE
CAUCUS OF MOTHERS SISTERS
DAUGHTERS.
GRANDMOTHERS ARMA PRABHA. TO SIX
WONDERFUL GRANDCHILDREN.
SOME OF WHOM HAVE EXPERIENCED.
THE HATRED OF ANTI SEMITISM
UNBEKNOWNST TO THEM THAT IT
EXISTED EVEN AS YOUNGSTERS
HATRED AND BIGOTRY.
THAT MANY OF US I WOULD SUSPECT
MOST JEWS HAVE AT SOME TIME OR
ANOTHER IN THEIR LIVES
EXPERIENCED.
BEING CALLED THE KITE TAKEN OUT
OUR GARBAGE.
WHEN I WAS ELEVEN YEARS OLD?
BY THREE CHILDREN I HAD NEVER
MET BEFORE MY LIFE -- THIS IS A
PROBLEM THAT DOESN'T SEEM TO GO
AWAY.
WE HAVE HATRED AND BIGOTRY IN
OUR SOCIETY WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO
ARE SUCCUMB TO THE WORST OF
THEIR FEARS AND THEIR IGNORANCE
AND THEIR INTOLERANCE. TO BRING
UP THE BASIS STAND US WE SAW
THAT IT POWER WAY WE SAW THAT A
TREE OF LIFE WE'VE SEEN THAT IN
SRI LANKA WE'VE SEEN AT ALL
AROUND THE WORLD.
BUT I RISE TODAY IS A JEW
[inaudible]
BECAUSE ANTISEMITISM IS A
SCOURGE ON HUMANITY THAT HAS
GONE ON FOR THOUSANDS OF YEARS.
I RISE TODAY AS A TRUE.
AND AS A WOMAN TO RECOGNIZE AND
REINFORCE THE FACT THAT ONLY
SEVENTY YEARS AGO.
A DEMAGOGUE NAME ADOLF HITLER
PERSUADED PEOPLE HUMAN BEINGS.
THAT JEWS WERE A PLAGUE ON THE
WORLD.
AND TOGETHER WITH THEIR
ACQUIESCENCE MURDERED SIX
MILLION JEWS.
AND SEVEN MILLION OTHER PEOPLE
FROM GYPSIES THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
HOMOSEXUAL PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T
LOOK LIKE THE GRADE ARIAN RACE.
AND SO WE'RE HERE SEVENTY YEARS
LATER.
AND YET ANTI SEMITISM HASN'T
GONE AWAY [inaudible]
CHAU.
I WOULD LIKE TO JUST FOCUS A
LITTLE BIT ON WHAT HAPPENED
SEVENTY YEARS AGO BECAUSE SHOWS
GOOD SENATOR FROM SACRAMENTO
REMINDED US.
PEOPLE MARKED THE FACT OF THE
HOLOCAUST.
I HAVE SEEN PEOPLE WHO HAD
NUMBERS WRITTEN ON THE INSIDES
OF THEIR ARMS AND I WILL TELL
YOU ONE OF THE REASONS THAT THE
****.
IN THEIR IN HUMANITY DID THIS IS
BECAUSE IN THE JEWISH RELIGION
BEING MARKED.
IS A AN ACT AGAINST GUARDS SO
YOU WON'T SEE TOO MANY JEWS WHO
HAVE TATTOOS AND ALL.
IT WAS A SYMBOL OF DISRESPECT.
SO THE GERMANS JUST TO MAKE SURE
THE CHOOSE NEW.
THAT THEY WERE LESS THAN HUMAN.
PUT NUMBERS.
ON THE INSIDE OF THE ARMS OF
JEWS WHO WENT THROUGH.
THE CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
AND IN FACT IF YOU HAVE.
SUCH A TATTOO.
IN ORTHODOX RELIGIOUS SIR OF THE
CEMETERIES YOU CAN'T BE BURIED.
BECAUSE THAT WAS A VIOLATION OF
CAUGHT.
SO THERE WERE EXEMPTIONS GIVEN
BECAUSE OF COURSE THESE WERE NOT
PEOPLE WHO CHOSE THE FIND
THEMSELVES TATTOOED WITH NUMBERS.
AND IF THEY WERE FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO SURVIVE.
THE PRISON CAMPS IN THE IN
HUMANITY THEY SUFFERED THE LAST
INDIGNITY THAT THEY SHOULD EVER
HAVE TO SUFFER.
WITH NOT BEING ABLE TO BE BURIED
WITH THEIR FAMILIES IN THE
CEMETERIES OF EUROPE.
SO A REMINDER.
THE **** REGIME TARGETED ALL
JEWS.
RUSSIA KILLED OVER A MILLION
MY ANCESTORS HAD FORTUNATELY
LEFT RUSSIA.
DURING THE POGROMS ANOTHER
SPIRIT OF ANTI SEMITISM THAT
HAPPENED IN THE LATE EIGHTEEN
NINETIES IN THE EARLY NINETEEN
HUNDREDS AND I WOULD SUBMIT.
THAT A GOOD PORTION OF THE
JEWISH POPULATION IN THIS
COUNTRY.
CAME DURING THAT PERIOD OF TIME
SO MY FAMILY WAS LUCKY TO GET
OUT BUT NOT ALL MY FAMILY GOT
OUT.
I HAD FAMILY IN POLAND.
THEY DIDN'T LEAVE.
FAMILY IN RUSSIA THE DIDN'T
LEAVE AND THEY WERE MURDERED.
BY THE GERMANS.
DURING THE WAR SO I HAVE A
PERSONAL CONNECTION AS I SUSPECT
AS WE DO.
FIND OUR DNA SO MANY OF YOU HERE
IN THIS ROOM SURPRISINGLY WILL
DISCOVER THAT INDEED.
YOU HAVE ANCESTORS WHO ALSO WERE
JEWISH.
BECAUSE WE'RE ALL ONE HUMANITY.
AND THE FACT THAT WE FORGET THAT
IS PART OF THE REASON WE NEED TO
REMEMBER IT HERE TODAY
[inaudible]
SO.
NOT ONLY DID THEY TARGET JEWS
BUT THEY PARTICULARLY SUBJECTED
WOMEN BOTH JEWISH AND NON JEWISH
TO IN HUMANE TREATMENT AND ABUSE.
WOMEN MADE UP TO MILLION A OF
THE ESTIMATED SIX MILLION JEWS
WHO WERE KILLED IN THE HOLOCAUST.
WOMEN DEEMED CAPABLE OF WORKING
WERE FORCED INTO DEPLORABLE
WORKING CONDITIONS WHICH OFTEN
THEMSELVES RESULTED IN THEIR%
DEATHS PREGNANT WOMEN AND
MOTHERS OF SMALL CHILDREN.
WERE SEEN AS IN CAPABLE OF WORK
AND WERE SENT TO THE KILLING
CENTERS TO MEET WITH THE TRAGIC
UNTIMELY DEATH IN THE HANDS.
OF THE AGENTS OF THE GENOCIDE
MANY THEIR WITH THEIR CHILDREN.
SEEING THEIR CHILDREN COLLAPSE
IN THE GAS CHAMBERS AND THEN
THEY THEMSELVES DYING AT THE
HANDS OF THESE.
ATROCIOUS MURDERS.
GERMAN PHYSICIANS AND MEDICAL
RESEARCHERS TOOK ADVANTAGE OF
JEWISH AND ROMA WOMEN AS
SUBJECTS OF ON ETHICAL HUMAN
EXPERIMENTATION INDEED DR
MENGELE LAW WAS HISTORICALLY
KNOWN AS SOMEONE FASCINATED BY
TWINS.
I HAD COUSINS APPARENTLY WHO
WERE TWINS TWELVE YEAR OLD TWINS
WHO WERE THE SUBJECT OF MEGALIS
EXPERIMENTS AND OF COURSE DIED
IN THE PROCESS.
BECAUSE HIS INTEREST HIS
FASCINATION WASN'T WITH HUMANITY.
IT WAS WITH HIS DISTORTED VIEW
OF SCIENCE [inaudible]
GERMAN PHYSICIANS.
EXCUSE ME BEATINGS AND RAPE WERE
ALSO COMMON OCCURRENCES IN
GHETTOS AND CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
BUT THESE WOMEN LIVING IN
UNIMAGINABLE CONDITIONS WERE
RESILIENT.
MANY WOMEN IN CONCENTRATING
CONCENTRATION CAMPS BANDED
TOGETHER IN ORDER TO SURVIVE.
IN POLAND SOME WOMEN SERVICE
CAREERS OF INFORMATION TO CHOOSE
IN THE GHETTOS.
WOMEN LED MANY RESISTANCE
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE GHETTOS
WHILE OTHERS TRIED TO RESIST
WITHIN THE CONCENTRATION CAMPS
HIMSELF.
AT AUSCHWITZ. FIVE JEWISH WOMEN
SUPPLIED THE GUN POWDER THAT
MEMBERS OF THE JEWISH SPECIAL
DETACHMENT AND AJ WHICH BIRKENAU.
USED TO BLOW UP THE GAS CHAMBER
AND KILL SEVERAL SS MEN DURING
THE UPRISING IN OCTOBER.
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR THESE WOMEN
HOLD LEGACIES OF COURAGE AND
BRAVERY.
IN THE RESISTANCE OF THE ****.
SO WE REMEMBER WE SHARE THIS
BECAUSE WE DON'T EVER WANT IT TO
HAPPEN AGAIN.
THE **** REGIME.
AND THOSE LIKE IT OR NOT
UNFORTUNATE ACCIDENTS OF HISTORY.
IF WE DO NOT STOP THE HATE THE
INTOLERANCE THE FEAR.
THAT EXIST IN OUR NATION AND IN
OUR WORLD WE WILL REPEAT.
THIS KIND OF EVENT AND WE WILL
CHOOSE THE JEWS AS THE FIRST
GROUP TO HATE.
WE ARE BETTER THAN THIS.
WE MUST BE BETTER THAN THIS AND
ON BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATIVE.
JEWISH CAUCUS ON BEHALF OF
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS IS A
BARBER.
AS A MOTHER IS THE DAUGHTER.
I ASK ALL OF US TO JOIN IN AND
NOT TRUSTS SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION.
WHAT TO ACT IN THE SPIRIT OF
COMPASSION AND LOVE? FOR ALL OUR
FELLOW HUMAN BEINGS.
THANK YOU MISS PRESS.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON FOR
THOSE WORDS SENATOR WIENER.
I THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT ON
BECAUSE I RISE AS A JEW AS A GAY
MAN AND AS CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE LGBT CAUCUS -- IN
FAVOR OF A C. R..
FORTY ONE THE WHAT HAPPENED IN
pIN TERMS OF THE EXTERMINATION OF
SIX MILLION -- JEWS --
TRAGICALLY WAS NOT ISOLATED THAT
WAS THE MOST EXTREME -- AT
CULMINATION.
OF MILLENNIA OF VIOLENCE AND
GENOCIDE -- TOWARDS -- JEWISH
COMMUNITY -- WEATHER AND OF THE
ROMAN EMPIRE WHETHER DURING THE
MIDDLE AGES WHETHER IN EASTERN
EUROPE. FOR RUSSIA WHEN MY
FAMILY TO FLOOD RUSSIA AND
EASTERN EUROPE TO ESCAPE THE
POGROMS WHEN ENTIRE VILLAGES.
WERE BURNED DOWN -- SO THIS
GENOCIDE HAS BEEN GOING ON
FOREVER ANTISEMITISM IS ONE OF
THE ABSOLUTE OLDEST FORMS OF
HATRED -- AND IS WITH US TODAY
AND IT CAN HAPPEN AGAIN.
I ALSO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND -- THAT ALTHOUGH --
SIX MILLION OF THE VICTIMS LOG
COSTS FOR JEWISH OF COURSE OTHER
COMMUNITIES WERE IMPACTED
INCLUDING THE LGBT COMMUNITY --
THE LGBT COMMUNITY HAS ALSO BEEN
THE SALT OF COURSE THE SUBJECT
OF EXTREME VIOLENCE AND EFFORTS
TO ERADICATE US FROM THE FACE OF
THE PLANET -- GOING BACK --
FOREVER -- AND IT'S STILL
HAPPENING TODAY RECENTLY YOU MAY
HAVE SEEN THAT BROUGH NAY --
ISSUED A NEW LAW ARE PASSED A
NEW LAW THE SULTAN OF BRUNEI --
ARE CALLING FOR STONING -- OF
ANYONE WHO IS -- LGBT -- SO --
THIS VIOLENCE THIS EFFORT TO A
RADICALLY ENTIRE COMMUNITIES --
IT'S NOT NEW -- BUT THE
HOLOCAUST WAS IN THE ALTERNATE
COMBINATION OF WHAT CAN HAPPEN
WHEN WHEN A CON MAN WHEN WE COME
OFF OF THE TRACKS AND WE ALLOW.
THIS FEATURE THE SPIRAL OUT OF
CONTROL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER WIENER CENTER
DORADO.
THANK YOU.
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA
MONICA.
OF FOR RAISING THIS ISSUE AND I
RISE AS VICE CHAIR OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS.
A TO SUPPORT THE RESOLUTION.
OF NOT ONLY BECAUSE OF THE WAY
THE HOLOCAUST MURDERED
[inaudible]
MURDERED.
MILLIONS OF OF JEWS.
BECAUSE OF THE PAIN THAT IT
CAUSES. TO THE FAMILIES TO TO
THAT COUNTRY -- AND TO THE WORLD
IT CAUSE PAIN TO ALL OF US
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD -- AS
LATINOS IN THIS COUNTRY
[inaudible]
WE HAVE [inaudible]
FELT.
THE RACISM AND THE AND THE PAIN
OF BEING.
OUT OF TARGETED.
AND TODAY WE'RE TARGETED BOTH
OFFICIALLY.
THE OFFICIAL VOICES OF
GOVERNMENT [inaudible]
TARGET LATINOS.
AND AND HATE BECAUSE HATRED AS
WELL AS FROM UNOFFICIAL VOICES.
SO.
I THANK YOU FOR CONTINUING TO
RAISE THIS AND REMIND US ALL.
OF WHAT HAPPENED BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY AS SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID IS THAT.
WE HAVE TO BE REMINDED EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
AND EVERY TIME WE GET THE
OPPORTUNITY IN THE SENATE. TO
STAND OUT AND STAND UP AGAINST.
BIAS AND HATRED WELL AS SMALL AS
WE MIGHT THINK IT IS THEN WE
HAVE TO DO IT BECAUSE WE DON'T
WANT IT TO GET TO THESE EXTREME
MEASURES.
SO -- I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO
[inaudible]
CENTER BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE AS BY SHEER OF AFTER
AMERICAN CAUCUS IN SOLIDARITY OF
A C. R. FORTY ONE AND I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM.
SANTA MONICA FOR INTRODUCING
THIS TODAY AS CALIFORNIA
HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL DAY. FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS THE **** REGIME
BROUGHT RADICAL AND DAUNTING
SOCIAL ECONOMIC AND COMMUNAL
CARNAGE TO THE JEWISH COMMUNITY.
THIS WAS A SYSTEMATIC IN STATE.
SPONSORED TERRORISM.
IN MANY WAYS WE SEE SOME FORMS
OF THAT HERE IN AMERICA AND
AROUND THE WORLD TODAY.
WE STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS
AS WE WERE HORRIFIED TO HEAR
ABOUT THE SHOOTING AT YOU SHOULD
BOG.
IMPALA WAY.
MEMBERS WE MUST REMAIN BILL VOTE.
THE JOINT.
AND PROTECT NOT ONLY OUR PLACES
OF WORSHIP BUT ALSO OUR
COMMUNITIES AS WELL FROM
VIOLENCE.
IN SOUTH CAROLINA NINE AFRICAN
AMERICANS WERE MURDERED DURING A
PRAYER SERVICE AT MOTHER EMANUEL
AFRICAN AMERICAN OPPOSE SPOKE
CHURCH.
THE PERPETRATOR EXPRESSED NO
REMORSE FOR THE INNOCENTS FOLKS
THAT WERE KILLED.
JUST IN THE PAST MONTH. THREE
HISTORICALLY BLACK CHURCHES IN
LOUISIANA FOR THE STRAWWEIGHT BY
RACES ARSONISTS.
THE BURNING OF THESE LOUISIANA
CHURCHES RECALLED SOME OF THE
NATION'S MOST PAINFUL HISTORY IN
MANY WAYS OUR FOUR HUNDRED YEARS
OF AMERICAN HOLOCAUST AGAINST
AFRICAN AMERICANS OR THE
JAPANESE.
HOLOCAUST GET TO THE HOLOCAUST
AGAINST JAPANESE AMERICANS
DURING WORLD WAR TWO AND THEIR
TURMA CAMPS.
OR THE TRAIL OF TEARS OF AYE
NATIVE AMERICANS WHO WERE JUST --
PERSECUTED AND KILLED DURING THE
EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS.
AND NOW ARE BLACK AND BROWN
FAMILY SOURCE BEING SEPARATED AT
THE BORDER.
OUR CHURCH CHURCHES IN RELIGION
HAS BEEN SO CENTRAL TO OUR
COMMUNITIES.
AND ATTACKING THEM HAS BECOME A
WAY TO TERRORIZE A TO ENTIRE
COMMUNITY.
EXPRESSING ONE'S FAITH IS
FUNDAMENTAL TO NOT ONLY THIS
STATE BUT THIS NATION AS WELL.
PAGE SHOULD NEVER LEAD TO
PERSECUTION.
AS REMAIN AS WE REMEMBER THE
TRUSTEES OF THE HOLOCAUST WE
MUST ALSO VOWED TO REJECT ALL
FORMS OF HATE.
BIGOTRY TO PREVENT PERSECUTION
OF ALL PEOPLE.
IN THE FUTURE IT IS TIME FOR US
THE STAND IN UNITY ONCE AGAIN
DOCTOR KING OFTEN STATED WE WILL
REMEMBER NOT.
THE WORDS OF OUR ENEMY BUT THE
SILENCE OF OUR FRIENDS THERE ARE
TOO MANY GOOD FOLKS BEING SILENT
TODAY AN AMERICAN ACROSS THE
WORLD I ASKED FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD
SENATOR CHIANG.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
WANT TO THANK MY GOOD FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA MONICA FOR
THIS RESOLUTION I ALSO WANT TO
JOIN AS A CO CHAIR OF THE JOINT
API CAUCUS.
I JOIN OF MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
SACRAMENTO AS WELL IN THIS
MESSAGE.
YOU KNOW IT IS SHOCKING WITH
WHAT -- OF MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
SAN MONICA SHARED WITH THIS THE
NUMBER OF MILLENNIALS WHO.
DON'T KNOW WHAT OUR SHORTS AND
THE HOLOCAUST IS AND NOT THAT
COMPELLED ME TO STAND UP. TO
SPEAK TODAY WHO SAY THAT WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO REMEMBER.
AND WE NEED TO STAND UNITED.
THANK CONTINUE TO STRIKE DOWN IN
JUSTICE.
INTOLERANCE RACISM HATRED
BIGOTRY ALL OF IT.
AND I JOIN ALL MY GOOD
COLLEAGUES TODAY AND ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT AND GOOD MONDAY
MEMBERS.
YOU KNOW I'M NOT GONNA FALL THE
MILLENNIALS FOR WHAT THEY DON'T
KNOW BECAUSE THAT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY.
IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERY GENERATION
BEHIND SAYS KNOWLES WORLD
HISTORY AMERICAN HISTORY THEIR
OWN HISTORY.
AND WHEN I HEARD THAT STATISTIC
WHICH I'VE HEARD BEFORE I WAS
REMINDED OF A VERY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE.
WHEN  TOOK MY FIRST TRIP TO
ISRAEL IN TWENTY TEN WITH MY
THEN TEN YEAR OLD SON AND WE?
VISIT VISITED YAD VASHEM.
AND THE TOUR GUIDE SUGGESTED
THAT I NOT ALLOW RYAN TO TOUR
THAT THEY HAVE A MINIMUM AGE OF
THEY SGGEST WHICH IS I BELIEVE.
THIRTEEN AND I SAID WELL I
APPRECIATE YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
I SAID BUT WHAT KIND OF PARENT.
TEACHER OR GUIDE WOULD I BE. TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
THIS PERHAPS LIFE CHANGING
EXPERIENCE.
AND NOT DO IT.
YOU'LL HAVE TO TRUST ME.
AND MY SON AND OUR CAPACITY TO
HAVE OPEN DIALOGUE TO WORK
THROUGH IT.
I THEN WENT BACK TO THE TOUR
GUIDE AND SAID WE'RE THEIR
CHILDREN'S RYAN SAGE.
WERE VICTIMS OF THE HOLOCAUST.
OF COURSE THERE WERE.
AND THE LEAST WE COULD DO.
AT THE AGE OF TEN IT'S
UNDERSTAND IT AND LEARN ABOUT IT.
THOSE OF YOU WHO VISITED YOU
WILL KNOW THAT AT THE END OF THE
TOUR THERE IS A SEPARATE
CHILDREN'S MUSEUM.
WERE YOU WALK THROUGH.
AND YOU HEAR A VOICE THAT'S
RECITING THE NAMES OF CHILDREN
WHO WERE KILLED AND THEIR AGES.
OF COURSE AFTER HAVING THAT
EXPERIENCE YOU HAVE TO COME OUT
AS MANY THE NEW MUSEUMS ARE
DESIGNED FOR YOU HAVE A PLACE
FOR YOU CALM.
AND JUST SENT TO YOUR CELL.
AND OUR TOUR GUIDE ALL GAVE US
CLOSE TO READ.
AS I RECALL RYAN MAY HAVE BEEN
THE FIRST TO READ HIS QUOTE AND
TALK ABOUT WHAT IT MEANT WHAT
THE EXPERIENCE MATT.
MY QUOTE THAT IS STUCKWITH ME
EVER SINCE WAS A QUOTE FROM.
MR WE SELL.
NO HUMAN RACE IS SUPERIOR.
NO RELIGIOUS FAITH FAITH IS
INFERIOR.
ALL COLLECTIVE JUDGMENTS ARE
WRONG.
ONLY RACES MAKE THEM
[inaudible]
RACE MATTERS.
CULTURE AND RELIGIOUS VALUES AND
BELIEFS MATTER.
AND WE MUST ALL STAND UP.
AND IT KNOWLEDGE AND PROTECT
THEM SO WE DON'T AND LEARN ABOUT
OUR HISTORY.
SO WE DON'T REPEAT IT.
WITH THAT IT WILL GIVE ME GREAT
PRIDE TO SUPPORT S. C. R. FORTY
ONE TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT.
CENTER MORE LOCK.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
[inaudible]
YES I WOULD START BY SAYING
MAYBE AS A MEMBER OF THE
INFORMAL DUTCH CAUCUS -- SEVEN
NINE YEARS AGO JUST ALMOST TODAY.
THE NETHERLANDS WAS INVADED BY
THE **** WHO IS A NEUTRAL
COUNTRY.
ON MAY TENTH INSTEAD OF
ATTACKING THE BORDERS.
BY MAY FOURTEENTH THEY HAVE THAT
THE LUFTWAFFE GO.
AND HAD COMPLETELY LITERALLY
OBLITERATED THE CITY OF
ROTTERDAM AND HOLLAND.
SURRENDERED ON THE FIFTEENTH
[inaudible]
OF MAY.
WITH THE OCCUPATION 70%.
OF THE DUTCH JEWS.
WOULD DIE IN THE HOLOCAUST.
I HAVE VISITED THE AND FRANK
HOME AND IT IS IT IS APPROPRIATE
MISTER PRESIDENT TO REMEMBER.
AND AS A SON OF PARENTS WHO
INJURED **** OCCUPATION I
ENCOURAGE.
AND I VOTE ON AS C. R. FORTY ONE
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU CENTER MORLOCK BETTER
MINING.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS.
I WANTED TO JOIN IN SUPPORT OF
S. C. R..
FORTY ONE IS AN EIGHTEEN YEAR
OLD WITH A BACKPACK.
I VISITED DACHAU. ONE OF THE NOT
SEE.
CONCENTRATION CAMPS AND DEATH
CHAMBERS.
IT WAS LIFE ALTERING.
I THEN IN THAT SAME TRIP VISITED
LENINGRAD.
IN LEARN TO THE TWENTY FOUR
MILLION.
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS AND CIVILIANS
KILLED IN WORLD WAR.
TWO MY DAD WAS A COMBAT ENGINEER.
IN.
TUNISIA ITALY.
AND CO YUGOSLAVIA. FOUR HUNDRED
FORTY SIX THOUSAND DIED IN
YUGOSLAVIA.
THE US LIBERATORS 400-160-00800
GAVE THEIR LIVES.
SO AS WE COMMEMORATE.
THE HOLOCAUST.
WE ALSO COMMEMORATE.
THOSE FAMILIES WHO ARE PART OF
THE RESISTANCE WERE PART OF THE
LIBERATORS.
WHO MADE THE ULTIMATE SACRIFICE
REVERSING THE HORROR
[inaudible]
OF NAZISM.
BUT WHEN HISTORY MUST ALSO
RECORD.
THAT THE US GOVERNMENT WAS SLOW
TO ENGAGE IN THAT RESISTANCE.
TURNED AWAY A BOATLOAD OF JEWISH
REFUGEES FROM THE HARBOR NEW
YORK.
AND WE NEED TO DRAW A LESSON
FROM THAT AS WELL [inaudible]
NEVER AGAIN.
SHOULD ALSO MEAN.
NEVER LATE AGAIN.
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR S. C. R..
FORTY ONE THANK YOU SENATOR.
MADAM PRO TEM.
WELL THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
I WHEN I HAD MY THANKS TO OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA MONICA AND
TO THE LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS
FOR BRINGING FORWARD -- SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FORTY ONE
TODAY.
YOU KNOW MY A FEW MY COLLEAGUES
AND I GOT TO SPEND A FEW MINUTES
IN THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS BEFORE
WE CAME TO START SESSION AT TWO
O'CLOCK.
AND YOU KNOW IT I HAVE ALWAYS
ENJOYED -- THE FLOOR
PRESENTATION IN THE ASSEMBLY
WHEN IT IS THE ART RECOGNITION
OF THE WHOLE COST AND THEM
MEMORIAL.
AND IT'S TYPICALLY A SOLEMN DAY.
BUT IT'S A DAY IN WHICH YOU PAID
TRIBUTE AND YOU RECOGNIZE THE
HISTORY.
BUT TODAY.
TODAY SHOULD BE THAT SOLEMN DAY
FOR YOU RECOGNIZE AND YOU
REMEMBER.
AND YOU PAY A YOU KNOW HONOR TO
THE HISTORY OF WHAT HAPPENED.
AND THE LOSS OF SIX MORE THAN
SIX MILLION LIVES.
DURING WORLD WAR TWO BUT TODAY
WAS EVEN MORE.
SOLEMN IN A WAY THAT IT SHOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN -- YOU KNOW I A I
GREW UP ON THE EAST COAST IN A
RURAL COMMUNITY THERE WAS NOT A
LOT OF DIVERSITY.
PRETTY HOMOGENOUS AND SO I GET
TO READ ABOUT THE HISTORY BOOKS
YOU KNOW THAT'S WHERE I
EXPERIENCED AND LEARNED.
ABOUT WORLD WAR TWO ALTHOUGH MY
DAD SERVED IN WORLD WAR.
TWO I AND I HEARD.
STORIES FROM HIM OUR THAT WERE A
LITTLE DIFFERENT -- THAN THE
HISTORY BOOKS.
BUT IT WASN'T UNTIL I MOVED TO
CALIFORNIA THAT I ACTUALLY HAD
THE REAL.
FORTUNE AND THE HONOR TO TOUCH
HISTORY.
WHETHER IT WAS A THROUGH OUR
PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY KNEW
REVEREND MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR.
OUR CESAR CHAVEZ AS MY
COLLEAGUES HERE.
HAVE SHARED STORIES OR HARVEY
MILK PEOPLE THAT I KNOW WHO
SERVED AND WORKED WITH HIM.
IN A SAN FRANCISCO.
ALL WE'RE WE ACTUALLY GET TO
TOUCH HISTORY.
AND IT SO IN REACHED MY LIFE TO
ACTUALLY KNOW AND BE ABLE TO SAY
THAT I DID JUST READ ABOUT THAT
IN A BOOK.
AND SO THE CEREMONY THAT WE HAVE
THE RESOLUTION THAT WE PAY HONOR
TO TODAY IN THE CEREMONY ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
IN RICH MY LIFE BECAUSE THERE
ARE STILL INDIVIDUALS WHO COME.
IT'S GOTTEN HARDER EVERY YEAR TO
FIND SURVIVORS AND ACTUALLY
PEOPLE WHO HELPED IN THE
LIBERATION.
AND CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN
AND I ALWAYS READ THE STORIES
AND IF YOU GET A CHANCE I KNOW
THAT MEMBERS OF THE A
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS WILL
SHARE.
THIS WITH YOU WHEN YOU CAN READ
THE STORIES AND I LOOK.
AT THE STORIES OF SOME AND I AM
JUST MOVE BECAUSE THESE ARE REAL
LIVES CONNECTED TO REAL PEOPLE
WHO WERE IN FRONT OF US TODAY
THEY'RE NOT JUST IN THE BOOKS.
AN AS WERE HERE TODAY -- YOU
KNOW -- TO SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION AND TALK TO HONOR THE
WORK ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR AS WE
SPEAK -- MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTEE KNOWS AND WE'LL TALK
ABOUT THIS ARE IN A MINUTE AND
AS WE DO AN ADJOURNMENT LATER.
THAT THERE IS A CONSTITUENT OF
HIS MISS LAURIE K. WHO SERVICES
GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE OF THE TRAGEDY THAT
HAPPENED ON SATURDAY IN A WAY.
AND SO YET ANOTHER TRAGEDY ARE A
SHOOTING THAT IS HIT HOME IN OUR
COMMUNITY THERE'S NO PLACE IN
OUR COMMUNITY FOR THIS KIND OF
HATE I DON'T CARE WHERE WE GREW
UP.
I DON'T CARE.
WHAT WE LEARNED ARE IN THE
COMMUNITY IN WHICH WE GREW AND
WHAT WE LACKED IN TERMS OF REAL
KNOWLEDGE AND HISTORY OUR HEARTS
ARE BIGGER THAN THAT?
OUR HEARTS ARE BIGGER THAN THAT
WE ARE BETTER THAN THAT.
WE KNOW IT.
I SO APPRECIATE THE PRAYER OF
FOR MARCH CHAPLAIN THIS MORNING.
SHE ALWAYS MANAGES TO HIT.
HIT THE RIGHT TONE AND AND
MOMENT OF WHERE WE ARE ANGER
ENCOURAGE.
WE HAVE TO LET THAT ANGER MOVE
US TO EXHIBIT THAT COURAGE. TO
REALLY STANDUP AND SAY THIS IS
NOT WHO WE ARE.
THIS IS NOT WHO WE ARE IN ANY
COMMUNITY IN AMERICA.
WE CAN DO BETTER.
SO AS OUR HEARTS CONTINUE TO
BREAK FOR YET ONE MORE FAMILY
ONE MORE COMMUNITY THAT HAS
SUFFERED INCREDIBLE LOS.
LET US MAKE SURE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO DO THE KINDS OF
RESOLUTIONS LIKE THIS.
THERE IS NEEDED TODAY.
AND EVERY YEAR.
YOU KNOW WE WE STAND AND WE DO
THIS WEEK IN WEEK.
WE FEEL THE PASSION IN THE SENSE
OF WHY IT IS SO IMPORTANT WE
HAVE TO TAKE THIS OUT OF THIS
CHAMBER.
AND MAKE SURE THAT EVERYTHING WE
DO.
REFLECTS WHO WE ASPIRE TO BE AS
A COMMUNITY.
AND SO TO MY COLLEAGUES.
I THANK YOU FOR THIS RESOLUTION
IT IS MORE MEANINGFUL.
THAN EVER BEFORE.
AND I ENCOURAGE ALL OF US -- TO
OF COURSE SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION THAT'S THE EASY PART.
THAT'S THE EASY PART BUT THEN TO
TAKE IT OUT OF HERE AND MAKE
SURE.
THAT WE LET OUR LIGHT SHINE IN A
WAY THAT SHOWS LOVE NOT HATE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE WIDE -- WISE
WORDS SENATOR JONES.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF S. C. R. -- FORTY ONE WHICH
HAS BEEN STATED HAS A SPECIAL --
MEETING AT THIS YEAR FOR ALL OF
US -- MY GRANDMOTHER'S FAMILY
AND MY GRANDFATHER'S FAMILY LEFT
GERMANY IN THE EARLY NINETEEN
HUNDREDS WELL BEFORE THE
HOLOCAUST IN THEIR HORRIFIC --
INCIDENCES THAT ARE BROUGHT UPON
OUR COUNTRY OUR WORLD.
AND I I WAS VERY CLOSE TO MY
GRANDMOTHER AND ONE THING SHE
WAS VERY CLEAR ABOUT GROWING UP
AS SHE WOULD NOT TOLERATE HATRED.
SHE WOULD NOT TOLERATE RACISM.
AND SHE WOULD NOT TOLERATE --
DISUNITY.
AND I SHE UP POURED THAT INTO
HER FAMILY SIXTEEN GRAND
CHILDREN.
MEMBERS LATER TODAY I'LL ASK THE
SENATE TO JOIN IN MEMORY OF
LAURIE GILBERT K. -- CONSTITUENT
OF MINE FROM POWER WE CALIFORNIA.
AND WE'LL TALK ABOUT A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT HER LATER.
BUT IN -- LIKE IN A LOT OF
TRAGEDIES OUT OF THOSE TRAGEDIES
COME STORIES OF HEROISM.
AND I JUST WANT -- TO BRIEFLY
MENTION A FEW FROM SATURDAY.
JONATHAN MORALIS AN OFF DUTY
BORDER PATROL AGENT AN OSCAR
STEWART.
AND IRAQ WAR A WAR ARMY VETERAN
WERE IN THE SYNAGOGUE DURING THE
PASSOVER SERVICE.
AND DID NOT HESITATE TO STEP UP.
OSCAR RAN TO FIRE WHEN HE HEARD
THE GUNSHOT.
IT WAS HIS MILITARY INSTINCT.
THE ALL THAT THE GAS GUNMAN AND
CAUGHT UP TO HIS VEHICLE.
JONATHAN FIRED AT THE GUNMEN'S
CAR ANY WITH AS HE WAS DRIVING
AWAY.
AND BOTH OF THESE MEN RISKED
THEIR LIVES AND PREVENTED THE
SHOOTING FROM BECOMING EVEN
WORSE.
I MET NóI AT THE HAN ON
SATURDAY EVENING AT THE VIGIL AT
THE COMMUNITY VISUAL THIS EIGHT
YEAR OLD GIRL WAS ONE OF THE
VICTIMS.
THAT WAS SHOT.
BUT SHORTER IRRESISTIBLE
CHEERFULNESS.
THAT IS FULL OF LIFE I WAS
AMAZED THAT.
AS HER WOUNDS WERE STILL
APPARENT ON HER FACE.
THAT SHE WAS HAPPY AND CHEERFUL
AND ENCOURAGING THE REST OF US.
TO BE HAPPY AND CHEERING ON THE
RABBI AS HE SPOKE THAT EVEN.
THE NOISE UNCLE ALMOG PARENTS.
WAS ALSO INJURED IN THE LEG AND
WAS THERE THAT EVENING AND WITH
A WOUNDED LEG HOP THE FENCE --
TO STAND NEXT TO THE RABBI SO
THAT HE CAN ENCOURAGE THE RABBI
AS THE RABBI SPOKE.
AND I'LL SHARE A LITTLE BIT
LATER ON I HAVE A NEW HERO.
IN THIS WORLD TODAY [inaudible]
RABBI.
ISRAEL GOLDSTINE.
WHO RIGHT NOW IS PERFORMING THE
FUNERAL? FOR LAURIE K..
WITH A MISSING FINGER.
A MISSING FINGER.
AND A HOLE IN THE OTHER HAND.
I WANT YOU TO IMAGINE THIS ALL
FIVE FOOT FIVE OF THEM.
BOTH HANDS BANDAGED UP.
ENCOURAGING HIS COMMUNITY.
THEY HAD JUST SURVIVED THIS
HORRIBLE INCIDENT [inaudible]
ON FRIDAY.
ENCOURAGING THEM TO LOVE. TO
SHOW COMPASSION. TO BE UNITED.
AT TO STAY STRONG.
HE IS MY NEW HERO.
I THANK SENATOR ALLEN FOR
MENTIONING THE HOLOCAUST MUSEUM.
CAN I JUST THINK -- AS HE SHARED
THAT STORY OF THIS YOUNG MAN.
ON FRIDAY IN SAN DIEGO AND I HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY.
AS MY WIFE AND I DID TWO TOURS.
THE TRAVELING.
EXHIBITION EXHIBITION FROM THE
HOLOCAUST MUSEUM WHEN IT CAME TO
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
FAIR A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO.
AND I CONSIDERED MYSELF A
STUDENT OF WORLD WAR TWO AND AND
SOMEBODY THAT UNDERSTAND
UNDERSTOOD HISTORY.
UNDERSTOOD THE HOLOCAUST THE
ATROCITIES THAT HAPPENED.
BUT EVEN.
WITH THAT.
DURING THE THE HOLOCAUST MUSEUM.
AND THIS WAS A JUST A PORTION OF
THE EXHIBITION JUST A A COUPLE
OF WALLS OF INFORMATION FROM THE
HOLOCAUST.
MOVED ME DEEPLY.
AND GAVE ME A GREATER
UNDERSTANDING IT.
OF SOMETHING I THOUGHT I ALREADY
UNDERSTOOD.
AND SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE ALL OF
US -- IF THAT.
TRAVELING EXHIBITION COMES TO
YOUR DISTRICT TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU SUPPORT IT PROMOTE IT.
AND GET AS MANY OF OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE OUT THERE TO SEE IT AS
POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
AND I DO SUPPORT SCR FORTY ONE
AND ASK FOR ALL OF US TO VOTE HI.
THANK YOU SENATOR JONES
[inaudible]
CENTER ALLEN [inaudible]
MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU SENATOR JONES -- AND I
WANTED THANK YOU FOR YOUR PHONE
CALL TO ME.
OUR FOR RUSHING OUT AND BEING
THERE WITH OUR COMMUNITY EMPOWER
WAY IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE
TRAGEDY -- YOUR ATTENTIVENESS
YOUR LOVE YOUR CARING FOR YOUR
CONSTITUENTS AND AND OUR FELLOW
CALIFORNIANS WITH SO EVAN AND I
JUST.
ARE WE SEE OUR HEARTS GO OUT TO
THE TO YOUR COMMUNITY AND IN
THIS MOMENT A TRAGEDY.
I THANK YOU ALSO TO ALL MY ALL
MY COLLEAGUES A HEARTFELT
COMMENTS WERE SO -- WE'RE WE'RE
SO MOVING AND TOUCHING TO ME AND
AND AND AND PEOPLE PEOPLE FROM
FROM ALL DIFFERENT WALKS OF LIFE.
FROM THEIR HEARTS I KNOW YOU
SPEAK FOR YOUR CONSTITUENTS IN
YOUR SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION --
I I DO WANT -- TO TO TO WELCOME
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU TO A
RECEPTION THAT WILL BE HAPPENING
AFTER ADJOURNMENT -- THERE YOU
CAN MEET VISITING HOLOCAUST
SURVIVORS WHO ARE HERE ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR RIGHT NOW
COMMUNITY LEADERS WERE ALSO CAN
BE JOINED BY OUR GOVERNOR.
OR LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR SPEAKER
THE ISRAELI CONSUL GENERAL. TO
NORTH CALIFORNIA.
ALSO FOR THOSE OF YOU HAVEN'T
EXPERIENCED IT YET AND CENTER
MITCHELL JUST CAME AND SPOKE TO
ME -- YOU ACTUALLY CAN INTERACT
WITH THE OF VIRTUAL HOLOCAUST
SURVIVOR ALL DAY.
IN ROOM.
ONE FIFTEEN IT'S AN AMAZING
PIECE OF TECHNOLOGY -- CALLED
DIMENSIONS IN TESTIMONY FROM THE
U..
SHOAH FOUNDATION AND IT'S A
WHOLE ACOSTA REVIVER WHO
RECORDED THIRTY HOURS OF
TESTIMONY YOU CAN ASK HIM
QUESTIONS.
IT REALLY FEELS AS THOUGH HE'S
SITTING IN THE ROOM WITH YOU
SHARING A STORY WITH YOU IN AND
IT'S A VERY SPECIAL EXPERIENCE
IT'S AVAILABLE FOR MEMBERS
STAFFERS GAS.
UNTIL FIVE PM TODAY SO PLEASE GO
CHECK IT OUT WHEN YOU HAVE A
MOMENT.
ROOM -- ONE FIFTEEN THE REASON
WHY OF COURSE THERE'S BEEN
CREATED.
IS BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THEIR
THESE STORIES ARE STARTING THESE
THESE THESE BEAUTIFUL CANDLES.
ARE START TO FLICKER OUT.
THE HOLOCAUST HAPPENED IN THE
NINETEEN FORTIES.
AND THERE ARE FEWER AND FEWER
SURVIVORS WITH US EVERY SINGLE
YEAR -- IS ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY THE JEWISH CAUCUSES SO
ANXIOUS TO SUPPORT OUR HOLOCAUST
EDUCATION CENTERS LIKE THE LOS
ANGELES MUSEUM.
OF THE WHOLE ACOSTA NETWORK
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO TO EDUCATE
THE NEXT GENERATION -- WITH
SURVIVORS TO TELL THEIR STORIES
RECORDING THEIR STORIES BRINGING
IN YOUNG PEOPLE TO INTERACT WITH.
THOSE SURVIVOR SO THAT THEY CAN
HAVE A PIECE OF OF OF THAT
HISTORY THEY CAN INTERACT WITH
IT THEMSELVES TANGIBLY BEFORE.
IT DIES OUT FOREVER.
BUT WE'RE WORKING HARD TO RECORD
THOSE STORIES AND IT'S PART OF
WHY THAT MISSION IS SO VITALLY
IMPORTANT.
SOME OF YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
WAS SURVIVORS JUST YESTERDAY THE
MUSEUM.
IN A SHARED WITH YOU STORIES AND
ONE OF THE STORIES THAT THEY
REMINDED US.
OF WAS THAT THIS ATROCITY.
WAS COMMITTED BY A CIVILIZED
SOCIETY GLACIER THE NATION OF
BEETHOVEN AND BACH.
A NATION THAT ADD ELECTED.
THIS EVIL MAN DEMOCRATICALLY.
I NATION OF SOPHISTICATION.
MEMBERS WERE ALL IN GOVERNMENT.
WE ALL RUN AN ENORMOUS MACHINE A
BUREAUCRACY THAT PROVIDES
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT SERVICES.
FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS.
BUT THIS MACHINE.
CAN BE TURNED FOR EVIL.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE SAW.
IN GERMANY THEY WERE THERE'S NO
WAY THEY EVER WOULD'VE KILLED
SIX MILLION JEWS.
IF IT HADN'T BEEN A BUREAUCRACY
OF SOPHISTICATION.
OF OF OF OF MODERNITY.
THAT HAD GREAT REACH GREAT SCOPE.
THAT INVOLVES SO MANY PEOPLE
PLAYING A A LITTLE PIECE OF THAT
CAR IN THAT GREAT MACHINE.
IT'S A IT'S A IT'S A IT'S A
LESSON THAT WE HAVE TO GRAPPLE
WITH AS LEADERS IN A OF OUR
SOPHISTICATED DEMOCRATIC SOCIETY
TODAY.
SO ON THIS DAY WE REMEMBER THE
VICTIMS WE GRAPPLE WITH THESE
EXTRAORDINARY LESSONS.
AND WE FIRMLY ABSOLVE
[inaudible]
NEVER [inaudible]
AGAIN.
I ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
ALLEN MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
BY BILL BY PORGES.
BY BRADFORD.
BY CARRIER [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
BY DOT.
BY THE RISE OF AYE GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER AYE GROW.
BY HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO BY HER TITLE.
BY JACKSON.
BY JONES [inaudible]
BY LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BY REAL.
BY NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH BY RUBIO.
BY SKINNER.
BY STERN.
AYE STONE.
NUMBER.
BY A COUNTY.
BY WINNER BY WILK HI.
FINAL TALLY THIRTY SEVEN I KNOW
KNOWS.
RESOLUTIONS ADOPTED.
NOW WE ARE MOVING TO PRIVILEGES
OF FLOOR.
SENATOR SKINNER ARE YOU PREPARED
TO DO YOUR INTRODUCTION FROM THE
PRO TEM'S DESKTOP MAJORITY
LEADER'S DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS -- AFTER A VERY MOVING --
DISCUSSION ON THE RESOLUTION AND
OF UNFORTUNATELY THE CURRENT
EVENTS.
THAT MAKE IT ALL THE MORE.
ESSENTIAL FOR US TO HAVE.
TO REMIND OURSELVES THAT IS
STILL UNDER WAY.
IT'S A HARD TO DO A A
INTRODUCTION THAT IS -- BUT-HOPEFULLY HOPEFUL TO ALL OF US
AND YOUR OUT YOU'LL UNDERSTAND
IN A MOMENT -- I ASK THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE TO JOIN
ME IN WELCOMING RICHMOND CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER CANNULAS JOHNSON.
DANIEL THIS IS AN IMPRESSIVE
YOUNG MAN HE'S.
TWENTY SIX AND IN NOVEMBER.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN HE WAS THE TOP
VOTE GETTER IN THE RICHMOND CITY
COUNCIL ELECTIONS WHICH MAKES
HIM NOW THE YOUNGEST PERSON EVER
TO BE ELECTED TO THE RICHMOND
CITY COUNCIL.
HE'S A FOURTH GENERATION
RICHMOND RESIDENT HE GRADUATED
FROM HOWARD UNIVERSITY.
AND AFTER COLLEGE AND STILL
TODAY HE WENT TO WORK FOR
RICHMOND HIGH SCHOOL AS A
COMMUNITY WORKER WHERE HE'S.
A MENTOR TO YOUTH OF COLOR A
COUNSELOR AND IT A MINISTRY --
HE GREW UP IN RICHMOND IRON
TRIANGLE AN AREA.
THAT IS.
UNFORTUNATELY STILL SUFFERING
THE LEGACY OF THE SERIOUS RACISM.
AND ECONOMIC DISPARITIES OF OUR
CULTURE.
AND THERE HE LEARNED HOW
IMPORTANT ECONOMIC JUSTICE AND
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT IS.
ANY BECAME THE VICE CHAIR OF
RICHMOND'S ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
COMMISSION AND A MEMBER OF THE
CITY'S POLICE REVIEW COMMISSION.
AND THEN WENT ON TO GET ELECTED
TO THE CITY COUNCIL AND I'M VERY
GLAD HE'S ABLE TO JOIN US TODAY
AND WE CAN WELCOME HIM.
THANK YOU
.
CENTER GROVE ARE YOU PREPARED TO
PRESENT FROM THAT PRO TEM'S DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
BEFORE I INTRODUCED OUR HONORED
GUESTS THAT ARE HERE TODAY I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY NOTICED THAT SENATOR
STONE IS NOT WITH US.
THAT IS BECAUSE HE IS WITH HIS
DAUGHTER WHO GAVE BIRTH TO TWINS.
TWIN THAT LITTLE GIRLS BOTH
WAYNE FIVE POUNDS MELA AND LIE
Là AND BOTH MOM AND DAUGHTER'S
ARE DOING ABSOLUTELY POSITIVELY
WONDERFUL AND HE WILL JOIN US
AND JOIN US ON FLOOR SESSION
THURSDAY.
SO MISTER PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
TOMORROW WILL MARK THE FORTY
FOURTH -- ANNIVERSARY OF THE
FALL OF SAIGON A DAY THAT WILL
LIVE IN INFAMY FOR VIETNAMESE
AMERICANS LIVING IN CALIFORNIA
AND THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES.
ON APRIL THIRTIETH NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE IT'S KNOWN AS BLACK%
APRIL AND WHILE IT'S MARKED THE
INTO THE MEAT VIETNAM WAR IT
ALSO IS A DARK DAY. FOR THE
VIETNAMESE AMERICANS WHO WERE
FORCED TO FLEE THEIR COUNTRY
WHEN THE NORTH VIETNAMESE FORCES
TOOK CONTROL.
IN RECOGNITION OF THIS IMPORTANT
DAY LAST MONTH THE SENATE PASSED
STATE SENATE CAREER RESOLUTION --
COULDN'T SEES ME CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SEVEN INTRODUCED BY
MY GOOD COLLEAGUE IN SENATOR
FROM SANTA ANA WHICH PROCLAIMS
THE MONTH OF APRIL IS BLACK
APRIL MONTH.
IN CALIFORNIA THERE ARE MORE
THAN FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND VIETNAMESE AMERICANS IN
THIS GOLDEN STATE WITH THE
LARGEST CONCENTRATION IN ORANGE
AND SANTA CLARA COUNTIES.
OVER THE YEARS THE COMMUNITIES
HAVE GROWN MORE BUSINESSES HAVE
BEEN SAID AT IN VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN FAMILIES HAVE SETTLED
INTO WESTMINSTER GARDEN GROVE
SEEN DIEGO IN SAN JOSE AND THE
CITIES ALSO HAVE THE NICKNAME OF
LITTLE SAIGON.
HERE IN SACRAMENTO SACRAMENTO-THERE IS ALSO A LITTLE SAIGON
WHICH RUNS THROUGH THE STOCKTON
BOULEVARD WITH ENTREPRENEURS
SETTING UP SHOPS AND RESTAURANTS.
TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
THE GREATER SACRAMENTO
VIETNAMESE AMERICAN CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE.
MISS VIETNAM ORGANIZATION IN THE
ASIAN REAL ESTATE ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICA TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
ANTHONY LOU WHO IS THE PRESIDENT
OF THE VIETNAMESE CHAMBER HAS
ALSO SERVED THE UNITED STATES
MARINE CORPS AND SO AND THEN WE
ALL THANK YOU AS WELL FOR YOUR
SERVICE.
ALSO JOINING ON THE FLOOR IS THE
FORMER CAPTAIN WHO SERVED IN THE
REPUBLIC OF THE VIETNAM ARMY.
A FORMER SENATOR FROM VIETNAM
BEFORE THE WAR STARTED MEMBERS
FROM THE VIçT NEED VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY OF SACRAMENTO
SHORT FOR VACA THOSE AND THE
REPUBLIC OF VIETNAM VETERANS
ASSOCIATION.
THE RAINY IN TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN MISS VIETNAM AND THE
REIGNING TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN MISS PHILLIP PROFIT
PHILANTHROPIC VIETNAM.
AND ALSO -- THE PRESIDENT OF THE
ASIAN REAL ESTATE ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICA THE WOMEN ARE DECKED OUT
IN THEIR BEAUTIFUL.
OZ SITE WHICH IS A TRADITIONAL
VIETNAMESE GARMENT AND OZ I
TRANSLATE INTO LONG SHIRT.
RATE LONG SIR.
ANTHONY I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE IN PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER AND I WANTED TO ASK
EVERYBODY IF THEY COULD JUST
GIVE A WARM ROUND OF APPLAUSE
FOR OUR WONDERFUL GUESTS
HONORING THE STATE [inaudible]
SENATOR UMBERG.
DAHLE LEVY THOUGHT TOM UMBERG.
YEAH I SAID THAT IMPRESSED MY
COLLEAGUES SAW.
IT IS APPROPRIATE THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THE DELEGATION THE
VIETNAMESE AMERICANS ARE HERE
TODAY PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF
S. C. R..
FORTY ONE AS WAS ELOQUENTLY
STATED ON THE FLOOR THE PURPOSE
OF THIS YEAR.
FORTY ONE IS THE RECOGNIZE THE
SACRIFICES.
IN THE ATROCITIES AND TO CONDEMN
THE ATROCITIES COMMITTED DURING
WORLD WAR.
TWO BUT IT'S ALSO TO REMEMBER.
TO REMEMBER THAT HISTORY CAN
REPEAT ITSELF.
AND INDEED IT DID INDEED IT DID.
JUST FORTY FOUR YEARS AGO.
TOMORROW THE FALL OF SAIGON.
WAS FOLLOWED BY THIS MASS EXODUS
AND BY THIS OPPRESSIVE REGIME IN
NORTH.
VIETNAM WHOSE SUBJECTING THOSE
IN SOUTH VIETNAM THE HORRIBLE
ATROCITIES SUCH THAT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS.
IN FACT MILLIONS FLED VIETNAM IN
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS DIED IN
ROUTE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS YET
STILL A NAME DIED LEAVING
VIETNAM.
AND SO FOR ALL OF US THIS WAS
JUST JUST FORTY FOUR YEARS AGO
BUT YESTERDAY I ATTENDED.
AND WAS PRIVILEGED TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE COMMEMORATION
THE BOAT PEOPLE.
AND LISTEN THE STORIES OF JUST
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS AGO JUST
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS AGO OF PEOPLE
WHO FLED.
AND THE PIRATES THEY PREYED UPON
THEM IN THE ATROCITIES THAT
OCCURRED AND SO IT IS MOST
IMPORTANT THAT WE RECALL.
S. C. R. FORTY ONE BRINGS TO
MIND BUT WE CONTINUE TO RECALL
IN YOU AND WE CONTINUE TO TELL
THE STORIES OF SACRIFICE.
ENCOURAGE NOT JUST FOR
VIETNAMESE AMERICANS BUT FOR ALL
AMERICANS FOR ALL YOUNG PEOPLE
SO THAT THEY KNOW OF THOSE
SACRIFICES SO THEY KNOW THAT
HISTORY CAN REPEAT ITSELF.
AND SO IT NEVER DOES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BAKERSFIELD FOR BRINGING THIS TO
OUR ATTENTION TODAY.
WE ARE YOU AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER ON BURKE
.
OKAY MOVING TO CONSIDERATION THE
DAILY FILE THE SECOND READING
FIVE FILE WILL BE DEEMED READ.
NOW MOVING ON TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THIS IS BE THE
APPROPRIATE TIME TO TURN IN
MEMORY [inaudible]
CENTER BATES [inaudible]
WELL.
OKAY JUST JONES [inaudible]
CENTER JONES.
THE JOURNEY MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT YES I
WOULD -- I DO HAVE A GYM IN A
GERMAN IN MEMORY FOR TODAY.
MEMBERS THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
ATTENTION I RISE TO HONOR THE
MEMORY OF LAURIE GILBERT K. E..
OF HOW WE CALIFORNIA.
WHO DIED IN THE SYNAGOGUE
SHOOTING ON SATURDAY MORNING?
PLEASE SAY GOODBYE TO LAURA
GELLER KAY WHO HER OAKLEY
SACRIFICED.
HER OWN LIFE.
IN ORDER TO PROTECT RABBI YES
RIO GOLDSTINE FROM GUNFIRE.
I AGREE WITH LORI'S FRIEND RUN
AT LIVE.
WHO SAID SHE DIED IN A
SANCTIFIED WAY?
IN A SYNAGOGUE.
ON THE SABBATH [inaudible]
ON PASSOVER.
SHE FOR US IS A HOLY PERSON.
IN THE SYNAGOGUE SHE WAS A
PIONEERING FOUNDING MEMBER OF
THE CONGREGATION.
FRIENDS IS STRIVING LAURIE AS
GIVING.
WARM.
ATTENTIVE TO COMMUNITY MEMBERS
ON THEIR BIRTHDAYS AND WHEN THEY
WERE SICK.
LOWER YOUR A JOULE OF OUR
COMMUNITY HER FRIEND AUDREY
JACOBS A COMMUNITY ACTIVIST
WROTE.
IN A POST ON FACEBOOK.
YOU'RE ALWAYS RUNNING TO DO A
MITZVAH A GOOD DEED.
AND GAVE CHARITY TO EVERYONE.
YOUR FINAL GOOD DEED WAS TAKING
THE BULLETS FOR RABBI GOLDSTINE
TO SAVE HIS LIFE.
WE SUPPOSED TO LACKEY HER FRIEND
SINCE SECOND GRADE SHARED IT'S
NOT LIKE SHE GAVE A MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A BUILDING.
BUT OF SOMEONE WAS SICK OR
SOMEONE DIED SHE WAS THE FIRST
ONE THERE WITH FOOD ARE ASKING
WHAT SHE COULD DO.
LORI WAS DEEPLY COMMITTED TO THE
CONGREGATION AND HAD RECENTLY
TRAVELED TO NEW YORK TO ATTEND
THE WEDDING.
OF RABBI GOLD SCENES DAUGHTER.
RABBI GOLDSTINE SAID IN MY OWN
INTERPRETATION.
LAURIE TOOK THE BULLET FOR ALL
OF US.
SHE DIED TO PROTECT ALL OF US.
ENGINE HE DESCRIBED LAURIE AS A
PERSON OF ON CONDITIONAL LOVE.
SHE DIDN'T DIE SENSELESS DEATH
HER FRIEND TOLD CNN.
SHE DIED ADVERTISING THE PROBLEM
WE WE HAVE WITH ANTI SEMITISM.
AND TO BRING GOOD TO THIS WORLD.
pPLANET IT WOULD HAVE BEEN LAURIE.
PROVIDE GOLDSTINE SHARED I
STARTED THIS CONGREGATION THIRTY
FIVE YEARS AGO FROM THE GROUND
UP.
LORI WAS THE ONE WHO HELPED ME
SECURE A CONSTRUCTION LOAN.
AND SHE'S BEEN A STEADFAST
MEMBERS SUPPORTER AND
PHILANTHROPIST.
JUST A KIND SOUL EVERYONE IN THE
COMMUNITY KNEW HER.
LORD BILL GIVER KAY IS SURVIVED
BY HER HUSBAND AND HER TWENTY
TWO YEAR OLD DAUGHTER.
WORDS CANNOT ADEQUATELY DESCRIBE
AN HONOR SUCH A PEROT AEROBIC
SACRIFICE.
WE SHOULD STAND IN HUMBLE
SILENCE AND SOLEMN GRATITUDE
THAT SUCH PEOPLE HAVE WALKED ON
EARTH WITH US.
RIGHT NOW AT THIS MINUTE.
LORI'S FUNERALS HAPPENING IN
PAOLI.
AND OUR COMMUNITY IS MOURNING
AND FULL OF SORROW.
BUT I THINK GOD FOR THE HEALING
IN THE COMFORT HE WILL PROVIDE
TO ALL OF US.
IN THIS MOMENT OF TRAGIC LOSS.
AND I THINK HIM FOR PRIVATE FOR
PROVIDING US WITH LEADERS LIKE
RABBI GOLDSTINE.
WHO INSPIRES IS ALSO ALL TO
REMAIN HOPEFUL?
WHEN HE SAYS I GUARANTEE?
I GUARANTEE YOU WE WILL NOT BE
INTIMIDATED.
OR DETERRED BY TERROR.
TERROR.
WILL NOT WIN.
HE ALSO SAID.
IT'S NECESSARY IN LIFE.
WE CAN'T IT JUST BE A BYSTANDER.
WE NEED TO BE AN ACTIVIST.
AND GET OUT THERE AND BE A HERO
[inaudible]
LIGHT [inaudible]
PUSHES AWAY [inaudible]
DARKNESS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE WHEAT
GERM MEMORY OF LAURIE GIVER QUE.
THANK YOU CENTER JONES OUR
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS GO OUT TO
LAURIE GO OVER QUE THE K. FAMILY.
THE SYNAGOGUE AND IN YOUR
COMMUNITY IN DISTRICT.
AND AND ALL PEOPLE FOR THAT
MATTER.
SEEING NO OTHER BUSINESS BEFORE
US SENATOR HERTZBERG THE DESK IS
CLEAR THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL.
THREE THIRTY WHICH TIME THE
GERMAN MOTION WE MADE WE CONVENE
THURSDAY AT NINE AM SHARP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IN THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM WHICH TIME
THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE WE WILL RECONVENE THIS
COMING THURSDAY AT NINE AM SHARP